you mentioned and many people mention
this that it's it may be that there is
some component of projections when it
comes to uaps
and then
it can't be all that because like you
said yeah
there's some physical evidence and then
i was thinking i've heard this from many
other people that
depending on the culture at a specific
time the beings if there are beings they
make themselves comprehensible to that
culture so for example perhaps they
appear to sylvan beings like woodland
beings or angels to later generations
right technology to us to a godless
nation however i don't think it can be
just projections because when it comes
to the technology side there were
reports of ancient flying roman shields
right and the government also seems to
be in possession of actual craft which
means they're physical so what accounts
for this
well
there's two kinds of projections we
think of projection in terms of our
you know let's say current understanding
a projection of something on a on a 2d
movie screen
right um
now
you can have sort of a holographic
projection
which is something which appears to be
there and you know as is in and of
itself emanating or reflecting light
there's a projection of something
potentially into your head that makes
you think you see something
but you know again if you're talking
about a technology that's
you know millions of years ahead of us
maybe it can project material objects
you know jacques uses the term often
the phenomenon can take a hold of a
volume of of space
and make
a reality real
right it can it can literally
change
space and
manifest
uh material objects
that's a form of a projection
at that point does it still retain the
word projection because
if something was created here then it
persists in multiple people
well i mean the question is is what is
created
uh actually functional
here in our reality or is it just a
piece of plastic that's moved from
behind the scenes
and made to look like it does something
so for instance let's talk about the
so-called craft
that people see i mean
i would like to think that there's an
object with a physics
and
a
a physics that can be understood
from
sitting here in our 3d 4d world
but
maybe
let's say there's a multi-dimensional
reality and whatever it is that is
driving these objects sits somewhere
else and it's basically something that
it pokes into our reality
and it's it's moving it from
elsewhere
it's made to look like it's moving
here
but it has no functionality here the
functionality doesn't reside in our
side of of the of the veil the
functionality is elsewhere
so you know we might get one of these
objects
let's say let's say there's a crashed
craft or or beings or whatever and they
are no more real than
a you know a a sculpted object right
they they don't have the they don't have
the function here the function is driven
from elsewhere
okay let me see if i get this analogy so
in there's this flat land which i'm sure
and
so if you're a three just for the people
of wondering what the heck that is as if
we're at least ostensibly 3d and then if
you look at your paper if you were to
touch your paper and there was an ant on
your paper that could only see what's on
the paper then all of a sudden they
would just see your fingernail and
wonder what the heck is happening and
you can remove it and they would just be
gone and violate their laws of physics
so
the purpose would be like imagine if i
placed this cup down
on the piece of paper the cup is
actually for water for me to drink right
but these people see the bottom sliver
of a plastic and they're wondering well
what the heck is the purpose of this
well that's actually not the purpose of
it they would be
unreasonable for them to come up with
the purpose right well and and if you
were to now move it through their
flatland
left and right
they would see no
nor even if they were to look at the
object where it is
right the pieces of plastic that are
interfacing in their 2d they would see
no visible means of propulsion
the propulsion the propulsion is your
hand
moving it left right and center
so imagine that this is what's going on
here that there's something else that's
it's it's the the the motility the the
functionality is sitting elsewhere
uh and then what is here is just like i
said like a projection which is being
held at arm's length and the purple
because even looking at this which is a
light right if at the bottom there's
just a base that's black and they would
right they would have a hard time coming
up with the purpose of that based on the
base so you know i think we have to um
be prepared for some disappointments in
a way because if if what i just said is
is true
we might get a hold of some of these
things and never figure out how they
work because
the the engine is not here
but the driving force is not here and
and so
you know it's it's but it is still a
puppet which is used to interact with or
in jacques
sense of the term
is the control feature the control
function
uh
the control system
is it still gets us to do stuff we still
dance around like a bunch of you know
like a bunch of monkeys when we see this
stuff
um and
its purpose whatever that might be is
is fulfilled
the monkey saw us
and then the monkeys will infer that
there's an intelligence behind it and
that's all we ever wanted them to do
to think bigger
to explore to explore the notion that
they're not alone
uh and maybe to of you know to
learn how to do this themselves someday
yeah
i think they don't want to reveal too
much because that's giving away the
answer in particular it's giving away
the answer for us to come
yeah exactly yeah and these are some of
the things i've said before is that you
know you you you never
you you don't give your child everything
you teach them and let them make a few
mistakes